[Musique]
c'était il y à très très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait la terre d'un
côté de la terre il y avait les jbe qui
passaient tranquillement leur temps à
peindre la campagne à chanter
de l'autre côté de la terre il y avait
des shadoks qui passaient leur temps à
guerroyer contre les arbres et les
petits cailloux
et tout le monde apparemment était
content
au début de notre feuilleton nous vous
l'avions promis les shadoks et des jib
il devait arriver sur la terre et bien
les y voilà
et notre histoire pourraient s'arrêter
quand dans les belles histoires on
finirait en disant qu'ils furent heureux
qu'ils vécurent longtemps mais ça serait
vraiment trop abuser de votre crédulité
car pour ne rien vous cacher c'est juste
au moment où notre feuilleton allait
s'arrêter
[Musique]
il est vrai en vêtements pour les uns
comme pour les autres allaient commencer
[Musique]
j'ai juré vous qu'un jour les vaillants
shadow que s'apprêtaient comme
d'habitude à livrer bataille à un ennemi
très supérieurs en nombre et il sonnait
du goncourt les friqués et puis tout à
coup c'était terrible beit qui en ce
temps-là régna sur la terre et les
shadoks ces indécis la l'avait réveillée
elle répondait la bête au joli nom de
gégène ou à n'importe quel autre nom
d'ailleurs mais en général il valait
mieux pas l'appeler quand on vous disait
que les vrais embêtements allait
commencer vous augmentez bien compte que
ce n'était pas uniquement une façon de
parler
alors notre histoire finira plus tôt
comme ceci
c'était il ya très très longtemps
en ce temps là il y avait la terre d'un
côté de la terre il y avait les jbe de
l'autre côté de la terre il y avait des
shadoks
entre les deux il y avait chez gégène la
bête qui les embête et j'adore kiné
gibily revient au bout d'un certain
temps ne pourrais pas vivre longtemps
sur une terre dès qu'un gène comme ça
alors ils décidèrent les uns et les
autres d'aller sur la lune qui n'avaient
pas de gégène du tout
[Musique]
oui